even though westerns used to be
extremely popular stories of masked
horsemen robbing steam locomotives and
showdowns at high noon hardly ever make
their way into theaters these days let's
take a look at the real reasons why
Studios aren't making many westerns
anymore
the early 2010 saw a few attempts by
Hollywood to strike gold with big-budget
westerns and in most cases the studio's
found nothing but disappointment the
first of what became something of an
unholy trinity of Western killers was
2010's Jonah Hex starring Josh Brolin is
the anti-hero gunslinger based on the
popular DC Comics character Jonah Hex
was a massive failure despite Brolin
sharing the screen with other popular
actors like Megan Fox and Michael
Fassbender the film only earned a
quarter of the 47 million dollars it
cost to produce next came 2011 s Cowboys
& Aliens which tried to weave a classic
alien invasion story into an Old West
backdrop the film was directed by Jon
Favreau who was coming off the hit Iron
Man 2 and boasted extremely bankable
stars such as Harrison Ford and Daniel
Craig unfortunately the movie fizzled at
the box office stateside and barely
broke even once it went overseas but the
crown jewel of Western disappointments
was 2013's The Lone Ranger one of the
most expensive flops ever made the film
starred army hammer is the masked hero
and Johnny Depp is is comrade Tonto
regardless of the star power and being
helped by blockbuster director Gore for
Vince key the movie was a huge bomb like
Cowboys and Aliens it needed to go
overseas to squeeze out a profit
originally The Lone Ranger was expected
to have at least one sequel but after
the film tanked studio execs were all
basically thinking the same thing don't
ever do that again
you can make a low-budget Western but if
you're looking for the kind of movie
that's going to compete with other big
action features it'll be pretty obvious
if you do it on the cheap she
and kill your people and your sheriff's
maybe
although it seems like westerns would be
affordable to produce with their simple
one Street towns and disheveled
characters wearing soiled clothing the
truth is that any authentic period piece
is going to come with a heavy price tag
a perfect example of this is the 2007
remake of 3:10 to Yuma starring Russell
Crowe and Christian Bale a new town was
built from scratch with a film but the
production ran out of money and so the
fact that the town was unfinished for
lack of funds was written into the story
and by the way despite featuring a list
actors like Crowe and Bale and earning
largely favorable reviews 3:10 to Yuma
barely turned a profit for some time
it's been predicted that China would
eventually surpass the u.s. and Canada
to become the biggest market in the
world for movie ticket sales this isn't
good news for westerns in the wake of
The Lone Ranger
Michael aggressed of the Atlantic took a
long look at why the genre was declining
among the many reasons agresa pointed
out exacerbating the problem is the
rejection of cowboy movies by
international audiences particularly the
Chinese it's another reason why the Lone
Ranger will probably be the last attempt
to build a true summer tentpole in the
genre considering how important China is
becoming to anyone making big-budget
films this could be the worst time in
Hollywood history to produce an epic
Western could be worse worse how could
this be worse think of westerns and
you'll inevitably conjure memories of
cowboy swapping stories and eating
around a giant campfire or traveling
across gorgeous landscapes on horseback
westerns can have plenty of long
drawn-out scenes that gradually build
the narrative and that's one of the
great things about the genre but when
you compare that style to something like
an Avengers movie where heroes are
blasting through cities and battling
armies of villains every other scene
westerns might seem a bit slow to some
modern moviegoers take a film like the
oscar-winning Unforgiven a practically
flawless movie it's still a beloved
Western decades after its release but
it's over two hours long and there isn't
a bonafide shootout until the final
moments of the film if you love westerns
then you probably appreciate the pacing
but if you're conditioned and non-stop
action you might feel like you deserve
more for the price of your ticket
deserves getting nothing to do with it
well the greatest westerns ever made
never relied on cross genre gimmicks or
special effects plenty of filmmakers had
tried to spice up their westerns with
modern sci-fi thrills
unfortunately it usually ends in
disaster one of the most recent examples
is Cowboys and Aliens which was a major
disappointment critically and
financially an older example is 1999's
wild wild west which fused a Western
with steampunk technology in the film
Kevin Klein's Artemus Gordon boasted an
arsenal of bizarre and occasionally
helpful inventions while the villain dr.
Arliss loveless played by Kenneth
Branagh was part man and part
steam-powered spider although it was
directed by hitmaker barry sonnenfeld
and starred Will Smith Wild Wild West
was quite deservedly a tremendous flop
that ended Smith's hot streak at the box
office one of the few exceptions to the
rule is Back to the Future Part 3 but it
was the third in a series of hugely
popular films that had nothing to do
with the frontier until its final
installment nevertheless the fact that a
time-traveling Western was a huge
blockbuster is still mind-boggling to
some crisps with westerns largely
underperforming against other big-budget
flicks movie studios are often in the
position of winning critical acclaim or
making a profit and for many the choice
between those two is clear take for
example the assassination of Jesse James
by the Coward Robert Ford while it
received largely positive reviews and
starred Brad Pitt's and Casey Affleck it
struggled to make back even half of its
30 million dollar budget more recently
there was the sisters brothers with john
c reilly and joaquin phoenix this widely
praised Western about a pair of unlikely
guns for hire made a mere 13 million
dollars worldwide and only three million
dollars domestically in many cases it
seems that today's best and most
imaginative westerns are being created
by independent filmmakers so the future
of this classic American genre might be
in art houses and not at your mainstream
Cineplex but if that means more
high-quality westerns on the big screen
we're sure fans won't mind one bit check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movie genres are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]